[Música]
a mí
e
[Música]
que poder utilizar el cuchillo como tal
dentro de una formulación de alimentos
para que si hay más gente pueda comer
alimentos
con coche y entonces también
investigando un poco me di cuenta que si
uno mezcla
alginato como un almidón
genera un enlace entre ellos que
importante gelatinoso y no obstante
discos o podría ser muy bueno para la
impresión 3d
bien
m
[Música]
específicamente uno va buscando según
las distintas figuras divertidas figuras
que puedan ser consumidas ahora el punto
de vista que le llaman cuando son
alimentos organolépticos visual los
colores el gusto también los sabores los
colores pero principalmente también nos
focalizamos mucho en la parte
nutricional ok o sea el producto tiene
que ser altamente nutritivo para las
personas de manera que tiene que ser
rico
también te ha roto méxico
[Música]